on Sunday evening Game of Thrones Season
seven premiered it opened with arias
start the wrong daughter of beheaded
hero Ned Stark taking revenge on the
enemies of her family
this led near a tendon the president of
Center for American Progress to tweet
quote Arya Stark is the flag for the
resistance who's with me
tendon is a former policy director for
President Obama there are two rather
large problems with using Arya Stark as
a banner for resistance first Arya Stark
is an assassin yes she's a fantastic
character she's fun to watch she also
goes around killing leaders in fact
spoiler alert she says midway through
season 7 she's going to kill somebody
who is in a position of power so if the
Democrats are attempting to tamp down
the violent rhetoric they're not doing a
very good job of it
second Democrats keep searching for
fictional counterparts for their current
situation
first they said at the Handmaid's Tale
is a sort of apocalyptic vision of the
trump era now they're moving on to Game
of Thrones the only common theme seems
to be that if a show is prominent it
must be a metaphor for Trump's America
but Democrats entire problem is their
failure to live in reality they seem to
believe the more they were tricked to
fantasy the better off they'll be there
was their lack of on-the-ground realism
that cost them the 2016 election and
their embrace of the enormous fiction of
intersectionality that continues to cost
them credibility still several craft
search for message and the only message
they seem to be able to unify around
instead of resistance even though they
can't even explain what they would do to
power I'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show all right so we have a lot
to get to today I know about the media's
attempt to assault Trump on a bunch of
different issues they're moving beyond
Russia now because they seem kind of
annoyed that they have to keep talking
Russian so now they're trying to hit
Trump with all of the old platitudes
we'll get to that we're also gonna get
to Trump's defense on Russia which is
not that wonderful plus we'll get to the
single greatest thing that the Daily
wire has ever released in the history of
its existence now what you'll do in
things I like still have to stick around
for that but first honestly thank you to
our sponsors over at texture calm so
textured calm is where you go to get all
of the material for magazines that you
would ever want to get we need more than
just opinions from friends or following
social media to stay informed that's why
I like to read in-depth sources like the
Atlantic even ones that I disagree with
Vanity Fair - The New Yorker you
get them all in one app called texture
with texture you get access to 200 plus
magazines full of in-depth interviews
and stories all in the texture app right
there on your tablet or phone
so Sports Illustrated as I say Vanity
Fair the Atlantic all these things you
can get for one low price texture calm
slash Ben its $9.99 a month and again
you get access to those 200 magazines
plus their back issues texture comm so I
spend you get a 14 day free trial so you
can try it out see how much you like it
my wife really enjoys using texture for
Reader's Digest
texture offers my listeners as I say a
14-day free trial
when you go to texture comm slash pen
that's 14 days to try it for free
texture comm slash Ben again it's $9.99
a month that would be like two magazines
if you subscribe to them instead you get
200 magazines from all sides of the
political aisle go to texture comm you
can see less texture comm slash been for
that 14-day free trial and again use the
slash pens that they know that we sent
you okay so the media are still focused
on this Trump jr. Russia meeting which
we'll get to in a little while but they
are trying to broaden their attack on
Trump now because as we approach the
midterm elections some Democrats are
starting to realize that just shout in
Russia at the top of your lungs in going
to do it because here's the problem
Trump was elected in November most
people just want the election to be
considered over even Democrats are not
that interested a lot of Democrats are
not that interested in relitigated 2016
forever we're just going to keep
litigating it until the end of time I
remember back in 2001 there's an attempt
by Democrats to relitigate the election
every five minutes but by the time we
hit September of 2001 and it was clear
that we needed a president all that sort
of receded into the past
there will be crises under president
Trump's watch because there are crises
under everyone's watch and I think that
even Democrats are starting to recognize
that it is a mistake to continue to hype
the the rush of stuff unless there is
new stuff that is coming out so we'll
get to what new stuff may or may not be
coming up in the meantime they're coming
up with new more typical Democratic
attacks on Trump so I think that a
couple of them pop out today one is from
Charles blow one of the things that I
think people need to understand about
the the resistance to Trump the anger at
Trump is that there is scorn for Trump
as a human being it largely Springs from
Trump's persona
doesn't spring from his policy Trump on
policy is a lot closer to Democrats than
say Mitt Romney was in 2012 or
George W Bush in 2001 the fact is that
the Donald Trump is a believer in big
government he is somebody who is is
mirroring a lot of Hillary Clinton's
policies with regard to for example
Syria his actual date hunt with Russia
looks a lot like Obama's date on with
Russia so it's very weird to see
Democrats out there going nuts over him
being nice to Russia when Obama was
really nice to Russia for eight years
and handed them controlled Syria and now
they're all upset that Trump seems to be
handing control of Syria to Russia so
you know Trump on policy is not that far
apart from a lot of the things Democrats
want but he angers them in terms of who
he is right there's a lot of
intellectual scorn for Trump and people
on the left and people on the right see
that as scorn for the common man but I
don't think that's entirely fair I think
some of it is scorn for the common man I
think that both the left does scorn the
common man the guy who didn't go to an
Ivy League school I know I went to
school with all the people who went to
Ivy League schools I won Ivy League
school so there's a lot of scorn in that
arena for the dum-dums who live in
mobile the country on the part of the
left but I think there is something else
here that is that it's getting at people
and that is that Trump is a he's such
Bulgarian that it bothers a lot of
people who see him as an interloper in
their circles Trump in other words is
going through what he has gone through
his entire life in his entire career
which is not really great for Trump
because Trump's entire stick and this
has been true since he was a young man
is that he's been treated as an
interloper in the in the halls of wealth
in New York City his dad was treated as
a guy who was new money not old money he
was sort of the brash American who ran
into the British circles almost and
Trump still sees himself that way and
the media still treat him that way until
you get an article from Charles blow at
the New York Times where he talks about
how Donald Trump's language is just
appalling it's just appalling he says I
know there are things of greater
consequences in Donald Trump's regime
than addiction but as a person whose
vocation concerns him with language I'm
simply appalled but from savage modeling
of that language listen I am NOT super
pleased with from syntax I think it's
ridiculous the Trump doesn't know how to
spell on Twitter but is that among the
top ten problems that I have with
President Trump no because at the end of
the day who really cares I mean it might
be a mild irritation but for the less
it's more than a mild irritation they
have cultural differences with Trump and
those cultural differences are not the
cultural differences they have with
conservatives
not about Jesus it's not about guns
which Trump is not in favor of really at
least you know now he's friendly with
the NRA but he was never a big gun
advocate for most of his career he
called for gun control
it's not about all of the typical issues
that animate the right and tick off the
left it's much more about they see Trump
as just as boar who somehow ended up in
a position of power and has never gotten
his comeuppance oh that's what Charles
blow is saying but it's not going to
play because it sounds elitist so you
know he's pointing out that President
Trump uses the word beautiful a lot he's
used at 1,500 times on Twitter and
speeches since he began running for
office like who cares who cares if they
think they're gonna win an election
based on this sort of nonsense that's
not going to work and so now they've
been relegated to using the usual lines
of attack they tried to use on President
Bush and on Mitt Romney and that is even
on John McCain and that is that he's
trying to assault on women assault on
women so what is Trump's assault on
women Trump in the past has actually
been very Pro Planned Parenthood in
terms of a lot of the things that he has
said Trump has been very kind about
about a lot of left issues on social
issues like I'm gay marriage he was much
more to the left than the traditional
Republican has been that still ticks off
the left there's an article in The New
York Times today from Michelle Goldberg
called the playboy president and women's
health and the entire article is about
how Trump is trying to take women's
birth control away from them now have
you seen President Trump have you seen
his wife have you seen his sexual
history do you truly believe that
President Trump is deeply intent on
going into women's bedside stands and
stealing their birth control the man was
on the cover of Playboy magazine hey
president Trump could not care less
about women's birth control but the left
wants to transform what is a political
difference about the funding for birth
control through insurance companies they
want to transform that into something
else they want to transform that into he
personally hates women even more than
Bush you know Bush was driven by the
issues but Trump he's just driven by
scorn for women and so Michelle Goldberg
writes at the end of her article again
it's this contempt for his character
this cumulative attack on women's
ability to control their reproductive
lives who'd be infuriating no matter who
presided over it but there's an extra
shudder of degradation in losing
reproductive rights at the hands of a
Lube richest playboy like mr. Trump
unlike longtime anti-abortion activists
mr. Trump doesn't bother pretending he's
acting in woman's best interests
hence his Frank admissions during a town
hall meeting last year that if abortion
were banned women having abortions would
have to be subject to some form of
punishment
there is no veneer in this
administration of compassionate
conservatism or promoting a culture of
life
there's simply power and convenience mr.
Trump doesn't care about women's health
or rights and it's easy to outsource
policy to the activists of the Religious
Right who help select him when you're
the president they let you do it of
course that's a reference to the
infamous p-word tape right so this idea
is the Trump is uniquely bad persons
it's not just the Trump is a Republican
and we hate Republicans it's that he's
uniquely bad person jumping on the train
about all of this is Joe Scarborough so
Scarborough who spent an enormous amount
of time in the primaries promoting
President Trump has now written an op-ed
in which he talks about why he's leaving
the Republican Party and in the top edge
because I did not leave the Republican
Party the Republican Party left it
senses the political movement that once
stood a fort history resisting bloated
government and military adventurism has
been reduced to an amalgam of talk-radio
resentments is very remarkable statement
first of all Trump himself is against
military adventurism he's much more of
an isolationist than he is a
neoconservative
as far as bloated government you know
Trump may like bloated government but he
hasn't been able to actually implement
any of it in fact the only major
accomplishment of his administration
except for Judge Gorsuch is the paring
back of regulations under his
secretaries under Health and Human
Service secretary and under the under
the EPA secretary that's this idea that
Trump is some sort of vast break from
Republican precedent in terms of policy
is silly again it keeps coming back to
character people on the Left do not like
Donald Trump because of character there
are a lot of people on the right who
don't like Donald Trump because of
character I don't like Donald Trump's
character but the attempt to suggest
that he is of a different kind in policy
because of his character is silly I
think you can make good arguments about
Trump's character whether he is going to
be a good president because of his
character whether he is capable of
fulfilling the expectations of the
American people because of his character
whether he is to knee-jerk whether if he
doesn't study the issues where these are
all criticisms that I've made a
president Trump but what the left is
trying to do is they're trying to say
that his character is his policy and
that is not true
they're trying to suggest that his
policy is way out his policy is super
crazy right that's just not the case
I mean Scarborough of all people should
be talking considering that
enormous amounts of time during the
primaries pushing Trump in spite of and
because of his various heresies on
Republican policy remember Trump did not
run as a traditional Republicans and now
the left is sort of at a loss of what to
do with Trump and so they're trying to
go back to the same playbook they're
trying to pretend that Donald Trump is a
traditional Republican except for worse
he's not a traditional Republican and
the flaws that Trump has are really
character flaws less than policy flaws
like I don't like a lot of his policy
buts present that it's a huge difference
from Dwight Eisenhower or george w bush
even is really really done it's not true
so the left is getting more and more
frustrated what's amazing about all of
this is that if the Left were truly
smart if they're truly smart they'd be
buttering him up because the truth is
right now they're in sort of a weird
situation they're trying to present
Trump his unique threat to the American
Republic there are two ways to do that
saying that his character makes him a
threat the American Republic and said
his policy makes him a threat to the
American Republic the truth is neither
one is a threat to the American Republic
I think that his character is a threat
to the character of conservatives who
decide to shy off his bad behavior but I
don't think that his politics are a
threat to the nature of the Republic you
know for all the talk about him being a
fascist that has not materialized in
fact the Democrats are stuck between a
rock and a hard place because on the one
hand they want to claim that he's a
unique threat and on the other hand they
have to recognize that nothing is
actually getting done so he's that
unique a threat then why aren't things
getting done Al Gore is out there openly
saying Trump isn't getting anything done
so okay if that's the case then why are
you also upsetting you've spent half
your life in politics some of it at the
highest levels second highest level
second highest mr. vice president that's
right what do you make of this young
administration so far every day it's
another another set of tweets and
another set of controversies and they're
not getting anything done his biggest
worry was what might be undone if mr.
Trump kept his campaign promise to pull
out of the Paris Accord he tried more
than once to change mr. Trump's mind
even visiting him at Trump town before
the inauguration did you find him
perceptive mr. Trump to your argument I
found him attentive and you can
misinterpret that for being receptive
but yes I did think that there was a
real chance that he would come to his
senses on this but in June this happened
the United States will withdraw from the
Paris climate Accord okay so the Al Gore
was saying that you know he's unique
threatened he's not getting anything
done and that's that sort of it's sort
of a weird situation that Democrats are
now in so because nothing is happening
they don't have a point of attack on
Trump and so they're forced to go to the
well with these old attacks I don't he's
trying to take your birth control or oh
he he hates women or oh he's something
to destroy healthcare right these are
all old attacks and they're not going to
work on president Trump now what is a
problem for President Trump is that his
own Congress is deeply unpopular so
right now Trump's approval rating in the
counties that he won from Obama is at
about 50% that is not high enough to
maintain a congressional majority it was
about 61% in those counties in the last
election cycle he's not about 50% that
does not look good for President Trump
which means that Congress is going to
have to fulfill its its
this is sort of the funny thing while
the Democrats are focused on President
Trump because President Trump gives them
a unified message the Republicans in
Congress would be a much richer target
for them because the fact is that even
Trump supporters don't like Congress
even from some most ardent supporters
look at Congress and say these people
don't know what they're doing now the
irony of the situation is that one of
the reasons they don't know what they're
doing is because the Trump
administration is not given them any
guidance so a Republican and confident
we the leading edge of the spirit may
not to give Democrats advice but if
you're going to run in 2018 on a winning
platform the winning platform shouldn't
be the Democrats are that the
Republicans are malevolent per se
because I don't know how I was going to
work the winning plan Hillary tried that
the winning platform should be these
people are wildly incompetent you should
never trust them with power and they
should be using the Obamacare debacle as
an example of that so the Republicans
keep running directly into the teeth of
the Democratic attacks on this and the
Democrats don't even notice Tom Price
who's the Health and Human Services
Secretary he was on the TV shows on
Sunday I believe this is on CNN and or
ABC rather and and here is Tom Price
trying to explain why Trump care is
going to work by the way Trump care the
vote is now been delayed because John
McCain is is been at the hospital and
they're trying to delay it until he gets
back to very very close vote here's Tom
Price trying to explain why it can be a
good plan what did they have to say
about this new idea this latest
installment in the bill to give more
power to the states
well what their concerns are obviously
and what our concerns are is to make
certain that every single American has
access to the kind of coverage that they
want for themselves and for their
families and the bill has changed
significantly so that we believe that
there is significant opportunity for
that goal to be accomplished the
governor's want flexibility they want to
make certain that they're able to design
their Medicaid program as they see fit
for their population but they also want
to make certain that the resources are
there to be able to cover that
vulnerable population and one of the
interesting things that's in this bill
that wasn't in previous iterations is
the opportunity to make certain that
those folks that actually fell into a
gap below 100% of the poverty level but
above where a state might put allow
individuals on the Medicaid system that
hole was not covered before this bill
provides
or coverage for those individuals
through the tax credit process and
that's something that's new that also is
one of the reasons that we believe we're
going to be able to cover more
individuals on this bill that are
currently covered I know that's
counterintuitive the folks that have
been reading other headlines but the
goal is to get every single American
covered and have access to the kind of
coverage that last line that is the
problem for Republicans and this is
where Democrats should run okay the
Republicans keep saying that Trump care
is going to cover more people they are
using a Democrat metric and the metric
for health care success should not be
the number of people covered you could
cover everyone right now if you just
made everyone eligible for Medicaid but
Medicaid doesn't actually increase
medical outcomes it doesn't make them
better the fact is the number of people
covered is not nearly as important as
the outcome of medical care what you
need is more medical care and more
access to medical care not health
insurance that doesn't actually cover
the people that you want the Republicans
are now using Democratic metrics for all
of this and this is the problem because
on the one hand what that means that
you're splitting the Republican base on
the one hand and people like me who say
free markets are the best and you don't
need everyone covered people get to make
their own decisions about whether they
want coverage you're not that people
like Rand Paul and I think Rand Paul is
exactly correct on this here is the
senator from Kentucky whenever it comes
up whenever Senator McCain is in good
health and comes back does senator
Senate Majority Leader McConnell have
the votes to pass this revised bill you
know I don't think right now he does and
the real problem we have is you know we
won four elections on repealing
Obamacare but this bill keeps most of
the Obamacare taxes keeps most of the
regulations keeps most of the subsidies
and create something that Republicans
have never been for that's a a giant
insurance bailout super fund that's not
a Republican idea to give taxpayer money
to a private industry that already makes
fifteen billion dollars in profit okay
so Rand Paul is exactly correct and on
the right we're saying we need less
regulation less subsidy but if you make
your goal hovering everyone through
health insurance no matter the quality
of the health insurance in America they
can keep their doctor no matter whether
it makes the life outcomes better notice
life expectancy in the United States
drops for the first time in decades last
year under Obamacare so this idea that
Obamacare is the cure-all is just
ridiculous but if you
Obamacare's metric as a metric of
success you're bound to lose the right
which doesn't agree with the metric and
you're bound to lose less in the
Republican caucus which says okay why
don't we just keep Obamacare and then
everybody will be covered right here's
Susan Collins of the left part of the
Republican caucus making that case do
you think that the bill will pass or do
you think there are enough other
wavering Republicans that it will not
they're about 8 to 10 Republican
senators who have serious concerns about
this bill and so at the end of the day I
don't know whether it will pass okay so
this is a big problem for Republicans
they have a caucus that is split on
their own it is easier in American
politics today to engage in the politics
of opposition than it is to engage in
the politics of governance
if you lied for years and years and
years then it's going to come around to
haunt you and that's what Democrats
found out after 2010 that's what
Republicans are finding out now now
before we get into the Democrats going
head over heels on the Russia stuff and
Trump's depends first I wanna say thank
you to our sponsors over at Zeile so
Zeile is one of my favorite services
this is a massage on-demand company okay
so what they do is you go to Zeile their
app you can schedule a massage at your
house they bring the table they're all
licensed masseuses they bring the oils
they bring the music the whole deal it
is a fantastic gift for a wife or a
husband for it for a parent it's it's
it's just a great gift Zeile ze Elcom
adds eels iPhone or Android app and then
you make sure to click add promo code to
check out you use my promo code and get
$25 off your first in houma on-demand
massage the first time we used it I was
supposed to get the massage my
mother-in-law was in town we gave it to
her instead and it definitely made our
relationship better I've doing it to my
wife I've done for my sister done it for
both my parents Zeile is just fantastic
7 days a week 365 days a year a deal
massage therapist qualified can be at
your door in as little as an hour and it
is significantly less expensive and then
you go going to the spa which means you
don't have to schlep it means the person
comes to you turn your house into a spa
it's zeal ze e l and again use that
promo code Bend and you get $25 off your
first in-home on-demand massage if you
sign up for deals massage mat a
membership you get 20% off all your
massages plus a free massage table and
sheet set a $380 value yours free
there's no initiation fee to join the
membership by the way
just a great additional savings on top
of the $25 discount that you get when
you use that promo code Bend so again ze
e L and use that promo code vents that
they know that we sent you get that $25
off plus it because the membership 20%
off everything and the massage tables a
pretty pretty flat deal okay so
meanwhile the Democrats as I say they
could be focusing in on the fact that
Republicans can't unify around this
stuff but if Republicans can't unify
around this stuff it's hard to portray
them as dangerous so what do you do
right if you're the Democrats and you
can't portray the Republicans as super
competent and highly dangerous and you
also can't portray them as so
incompetent they're going to break the
system what do you do and the answer is
you go to ancillary issues you look for
some sort of conspiracy theory with
which to hammer them you look for some
sort of evil action that you can latch
on to you paint Trump as an outlier some
sort of something deeply evil has
happened here and this is why the
Democrats are so obsessed with Russia
not only because they want to overturn
the election not only because they have
cultural scorn for president Trump but
also because they do not have a point of
unity because the Republicans are not
offering them a point of unity so
Republicans are not fulfilling their
campaign promises they're not getting
anything done but they're also not
offering them a point to run on so
inaction is actually the enemy of the
Democrats here if you're a Democrat what
you want it's for Republicans to pass
this Trump care bill so that you can run
against the Trump care bill and say that
Republicans just ruined your health care
but that is solved right now so instead
Democrats are now looking into ancillary
issues so we'll get to all of that in
just a second but for that you have to
go over to Daley wire.com we'll talk
about Trump's defense against the rush
of charges we'll also talk about some
things I like and epic things I liked it
I just an amazing thing if you didn't
see it yesterday we released it but it's
really great you're going to have to see
it's a game of thrones tribute you'll
have to see it and things I like but
when you go over and subscribe it daily
wire comm you can watch the rest of the
show you sort have to see it to
appreciate really for those who don't
know this show is a video show so if
you're just listening then you should go
over to daily wire comm you can
subscribe and you can watch the entire
show on video if you're watching us over
at Facebook then as you know the video
cuts off after 15 minutes but you can
watch the rest of us live over at Daley
wire.com and watch the whole show live
when you subscribe for $9.99 a month
you also get Andrew Clavin show video
live you get to be part of his mailbag
be part of my mailbag Michael Knowles
god help us
show coming out and so you'll be able to
watch that as well plus you get the
annual subscription for $99 you get this
unbelievable magnificent I mean it just
will make your life greater in every
possible way
tumblr leftist here's hot or cold it
says it right up on it in beautiful
silver lettering dishwasher-safe
incredible makes julienne fries just
spectacular so go over to Jay Lee Weyer
comm get that annual subscription and
you get the you get this this tumbler we
call it a tumbler because otherwise
steven crowder sues us so it this
tumbler is fantastic though it is it is
great high-quality a magnificent made of
gold it's not made of gold but it should
be okay so it shouldn't gold taste bad
fuses utensil in any case go over to Jay
Lee Weyer comm and subscribe or just
want to listen later go to iTunes or
SoundCloud and you can listen and leave
us a review we always appreciate it we
are the largest conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so how desperate are Democrats to pin
something on Trump with regards of the
Russia stuff they're desperate as I say
again to review for a couple reasons one
they can't get them on character
everybody knows Trump's character at
this point it is what it is
- they can't get the Republicans on
being evil because the Republicans
aren't doing anything and three it's
hard to get the Republicans on
incompetence because well it's true it
is also not something that Spurs people
to the polls in any real serious way so
Democrats are instead looking to
ancillary issues they're trying to find
another way to label Republicans evil
even while the Republicans don't really
do anything so Mark Warner the
Democratic senator from West Virginia he
comes out and he says you know we're
going to start looking into ancillary
issues about Russia like digital box yes
really
we've got more investigation to look
into I would like to also look into the
activities of Cambridge analytics I'd
like to look into the activities of the
Trump digital campaign I will point out
this Facebook which basically denied any
responsibility around our elections by
the time the French elections took place
this spring they actually took down
30,000 fake sites we also know that it's
been estimated eight percent of all
Twitter accounts are fake so the ability
to manipulate these search engines and
some of these social media platforms is
real it's out there and we need
information from the companies as well
as we need to look into the activities
of some of the digital campaign
activities are you whole thing here is
to create a miasma scandal around Trump
now Trump isn't helping with that
because the miasma scandal has attached
to him
and this Trump jr. meeting last week the
the revelation of it and the fact that
Donald Trump jr. himself released emails
obviously doesn't help along those lines
but just to prove the hypocrisy of the
Democrats on this stuff they are
hypocrites I mean Teddy Kennedy in 1984
actively attempted to collude with the
Russian government saying that he wanted
to work with them in order to take down
President Ronald Reagan and the Russians
basically pledged their support to him
Teddy Kennedy was a hero until he died
in the Democratic Party Adam Schiff was
there was a Democratic Congress person
from out here in California he says that
when Hillary Clinton's people were
meeting with Ukraine to get Oppo
research on Trump that it really wasn't
that big a deal or they've also pointed
to this - this issue with the Democratic
party and the Ukrainian embassy this is
this comes from a story in Politico that
ran in January the headline Ukrainian
efforts to sabotage Trump backfire and I
want to read from the article a
Ukrainian American operative who was
consulting for the DNC met with top
officials in the Ukrainian embassy an
effort to expose ties between Trump top
campaign aide Paul Manafort and Russia
the Ukrainian efforts had an impact in
this race helping force Manta force
resignation and advancing the narrative
that the Trump campaign was deeply
connected to Ukraine's flow to the East
Russia so let me ask you I understand
Hillary Clinton loss I understand this
effort was not as elaborate as the
Russian effort but was it acceptable or
wouldn't have been acceptable for the
Democrats to accept help from the
Ukrainian government in this campaign no
it would be a program for Democrats to
accept help from the Ukrainian
government but I think if you look at
the political article and we're talking
about just a single article here if you
accept all the facts in the article the
scale of what the Russians did is not
comparable to anything in that article
if it were the comparable analogy would
be that the Ukrainian president directed
the Ukrainian intelligence agencies to
steal to hack Donald Trump's campaign
steal emails publish them directly music
luring the issue right I mean the fact
is you're they're colluding with foreign
government in affecting the election or
you're not now I think the query line of
demarcation is that the Ukrainian
government is allied with the United
States government whereas the Russian
government is at odds with the American
government but it's hard for Democrats
to make that case considering that they
were considering Vladimir Putin and Ally
until seven minutes ago until the
election cycle Vladimir Putin was their
bestest friend so Democrats continue to
reach with this now the Trump campaign
the administration has a series of
defenses they could use for all of this
they could say number one Bob Muller is
already investigating this stuff
whatever will come out will come out
number two they could say this is all
been overblown everybody is making a
fuss over something that really is not
that big a deal number three they could
say Democrats are hypocrites which is
true it doesn't excuse our behavior but
for Democrats to complain about it is
pretty ridiculous all of these things
are true
instead the Trump team continues to be
really bad at this Oh Trump is leading
his own defense rule in lawyering never
be your own lawyer okay if you are ever
convicted of if you're ever accused of
and you should never be your own lawyer
you always get in the movies I'm going
to represent myself
okay people who represent themselves was
100 percent of the time president Trump
seems to be thinking that if he defends
himself despite the fact there's an
entire infrastructure of people out
there willing to defend him from talk
radio to Fox News I will defend him if I
think that he is right you know despite
all of that he feels the need to defend
himself and so he goes on the rampage on
Twitter and he starts tweeting about his
approval ratings and about fake news
distorting democracy here's what he
tweeted about his approval ratings his
approval ratings over the weekend were
36% he said the ABC Washington Post poll
even though almost 40% is not bad at
this time it was just about the most
inaccurate poll around election time
there's no need for him to do this
the reason there's no need for him to do
this is because number one it is the
worst poll for a president at this point
in his presidency in the history of
polling really 36% is lower than any
president in the history of modern
American polling and number two it is
not true the ABC Washington Post poll
was the worst around election time they
were actually one of the closest around
election time they had Hillary 49 46 she
ended up winning 48 46 in the popular
vote but the reason this is data is
because it undermines what is a legit
claim which is the media has done a very
poor job covering the Russia stuff and
they have blown up every single issue
into an end-of-the-world issue right
every molehill is a mountain in the
media's view that would be a legit
criticism but because Trump feels the
need to punch back on every single
report true or not true she ends up
undermining his own credibility in a
battle that he should be able to easily
win against the media so when he says
stuff like this right when he says about
fake news he tweets regarding fake news
that it is distorting democracy is with
all of its phony unnamed sources and
highly slanted and even fraudulent
reporting
fake news is distorting democracy in our
country that is true okay what he's
saying there is true but after just
tweeting that a poll that was pretty
accurate was not accurate and that his
approval ratings are not that bad it's
not he's not making a strong case for
himself now I do think that the
inaccuracies of the media are really bad
I think what's worse is the media
pretending to be objective so this is a
little bit of a subtle difference from
some of the things you're hearing you
know my friend my friend Dennis Prager
tweeted out over the weekend that the
media are more of a threat to Western
civilization than the Russian government
and obviously doesn't mean that they're
more of a threat to American citizens he
means they're more of a threat to the
the lasting the lasting conservatism of
the American people but what he
on fox news was we need an objective
media again I don't think there is such
a thing as an objective media I think
what we need is an openly partisan media
so what Trump is saying here which is
that they use phony unnamed sources and
highly threatened even fraudulent
reporting again you know doesn't get to
complain about this considering how many
unnamed sources that are phony he has
actually used including himself I mean
he used to use himself his own press
agent and call himself Jim Miller John
Miller but the problem is that this
critique is right it would be a correct
critique if you are honest honest people
can make this critique people who tend
to fib cannot make this critique about
the news media so that undercuts attack
number one attack line number one by
trauma attack line number two is just I
don't know if this was designed to help
trumpet it really hurts and actually Jay
Sekulow is Trump's lawyer and he's on
ABC News this week and he is asked about
this Trump jr. Russia meeting and here's
what he had to say
well I've wondered why the the Secret
Service that this was nefarious why'd
the Secret Service allow these people
when the President had Secret Service
protection at that point that raised a
question with me okay again this is a
bad line of defense because then the
Secret Service comes down they say well
he wasn't even under protection at the
time right he had me mourn the primary
chance we didn't even have Secret
Service at the time second of all Secret
Service doesn't vet meetings with the
president they vet it for security
reasons but they don't vet it for for
national security reasons right if you
decide that you're going to collude like
they want to make sure that Trump
doesn't get shot or his campaign members
don't get shot but Secret Service's job
is not to vet people who meet with the
President of the United States that's it
that that's that's a silly silly line of
defense and a weak line of defense and
here's the problem the weaker the line
of defense for the Trump administration
the more people are going to want to dig
and then you finally get to defense
number three and I think this is the one
that the Republicans ought to avoid we
are going to embrace I think that we are
moments away from the Republicans
embracing this defense full-scale a
Jeanine Pirro judge Jeanine on Fox News
she represents the same sort of it that
Donald Trump represents in the
conservative movement in the Republican
Party
she's sort of the headline version of
conservatism she shall say things that
are inflammatory and outrageous
sometimes but I think that her head is
where large segments of the Republican
base is and here's what she had to say
about this
Trump junior Russia meeting as someone
who's run for office
five times if the devil called me and
said he wanted to set up a meeting to
give me opposition research on my
opponent I'd be on the first trolley to
hell to get it and any politician tells
you otherwise is a bold-faced liar okay
so this is the new politics right Donald
Trump tweeted the exact same thing this
morning he speech most politicians would
have gone to a meeting like the ones on
jr. attended in order to get info on an
opponent that's politics okay well that
is I think how many people perceive
American politics but this is one of the
problems with pop culture and media
generally it is true that politicians
are corrupt it is true that politicians
are dirty and play dirty it is not true
that everybody in the United States who
is running for politics would meet with
the foreign government to get opposition
research on their opponents not when
there was a basic expectation of a quid
pro quo if you're meeting with the
Russian government the idea there's no
quid pro quo expected is relatively
silly but the American people have a
perception of politics that it is
ultimately dirty they think that
American politics is house of cards
Trump is not a government guy so it's
not as though Trump dispenses entire
life dealing with people in government
you know whenever Trump talks about his
fellows in government I had the same
problem with John McCain about campaign
finance reform he would constantly say
we need campaign finance reform because
everybody in politics is corrupt and I
just wanted to ask him one question okay
John have you ever been bribed by a
corporation what makes you think you're
so much more honest than everybody else
in your profession and the same thing I
would ask of Jeanine Pirro or of Trump
which is okay you know you think you're
honest but why are you more honest than
anybody else I guess the argument here
is they shouldn't be honest and nobody
should be honest in politics that we
should live down to our worst
expectation of politics if that's the
case then we are on a fast road here we
are on a fast road to something quite
terrible I do think that people revel in
the in the dirty of it I think people on
our side both sides I don't want to say
chase our side I think people on both
sides revel in the breaking the rules of
it in the hard-nosed of it as I talked
about last week but I don't think that
that's a good thing I think that good
people try to tailor the means they use
to the ends they seek to achieve they
don't revel in the means just because
it's fun to use the means and I think
that's sort of where we're going with
all this now again does any of this mean
that anything deeply nefarious was done
no I mean again I'm not somebody who
think that it's good that Donald Trump
did this but I'm failing to see the quid
pro quo I don't see what the pro quo is
I don't see how Trump has paid off
Russia per se yet I'm still open to
evidence but I haven't seen that I don't
know exactly even how the collusion was
done during the campaign as I said last
week there's a lot of talk about
collusion but I don't know what that
collusion looks like it looks a lot more
to me like the media are trying to seize
on top of collusion and have been for
six months now they have a bone they can
actually know on and that's Trump
juniors fault and that's Trump's fault
and it may in fact come out that Trump
was knowledgeable about this meeting in
which case they shouldn't been denying
things right the cover-up is always
worse than the crime but I'm skeptical
that any of this takes Trump down and
I'm skeptical the American people care
all that much other than the general
miasma the Trump is corrupt in some
bizarre way okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like we did this last week
we all got very enthusiastic about the
game of Thrones season premiere that
happened last night and which I thought
was slow but had a couple of great
things in it there's only three great
moments right there's one of the there's
one having to the hound
there's the opener and then there's a
good moment with an unexpected character
in an unexpected place I think those are
the three good moments of the premiere
but we got we got very excited around
here and I got out my violin and we put
this together last week the entire staff
put all of their work aside to make this
ridiculous thing that I'm about to show
you it is our tribute to Game of Thrones
[Music]
a
Oh
you
[Music]
mmm
you
so that was the thing that we actually
did yeah that's that's real life right
there that has it you know it just shows
you I think that what people are
interested in that video has combined
about 1.3 million views in less than a
day so well done everybody
really our staff was great they put the
whole thing together that is made for
those who couldn't see that is me
playing three parts on the violin but it
has some pretty wild imagery can go over
to Facebook later and check it out I
don't want to give it away if you
haven't actually seen it okay
other things that I like actually have
some pretty epic things I liked it today
so other things that I like well this
was pretty great yesterday at a baseball
game Yankees Red Sox baseball game there
was so the Yankees and the Red Sox hate
each other if you're not a baseball fan
fans hate each other I've been to
Yankees Red Sox game it can get really
brutal I was out in the bleachers one
year when people started pouring beer on
each other and fighting that is not
uncommon so at this Yankees Red Sox game
there's a Red Sox fan who's sitting in
the front row and he catches a foul ball
and here's what he does and the Yankee
fans can't make nice just a wonderful
moment of Sox fan Hanning this little
lady of the baseball watch what happens
next
very so cute very sweet very Haley so we
can all get along yeah it's really
really cute so this little girl in a
Derek Jeter jersey comes down and this
Red Sox fan hands our baseball and then
she goes back to her dad and then he
sends her back down and she gives the
guy a hug really really cute and so
baseball can bring people together even
though it can also separate people
obviously okay other things that I like
this is actually a bit of an old tape
but I just saw it for the first time
these cops pull over this black guy and
you think that this is going to go like
how all these other videos go which is
the cops somehow is treating the guy but
it turns out that they know the guy and
what happens next is pretty great hey
brother
as we go haven't seen you in forever
just got out of the hospital how we
going oh well I'm actually not sleepy -
yeah I got to be honest real I've
stopped just a childhood for my child to
be poking about hugs he said I do
and we'll see one
we do have a challenge car with no car
seat now you can tell you now Todd is a
great man oh this is awesome
take it out what's the thing dad bu on
your birthday
doing your birthday are you kidding me
do ah yeah keep going
okay I love my music they're all
different issues though you know there's
no attempt to make cops have to be the
worst people in the world in the media
at the only time you ever see cops is
when something bad happens obviously
that is not true and this is a terrific
video so I'm glad that I'm glad that's
out there okay time for a thing that I
hate okay so I've been friends with Ann
Coulter for a very long time and I've
been friends with them since I was like
16 years old 17 years old and she's
always been very nice to me we've been
very friendly we going to dinner many
times I don't know what the hell
happened on Delta Airlines but I think
this is totally inappropriate so I've
been in situations I was in a situation
American Airlines a couple of years ago
where I was supposed to fly in for a
speech and they canceled my flight it
was set for like two hours before the
speech they canceled the flight then I
could go gotten on the follow-up and
maybe made it to the speech on time and
they put me on the standby list and then
I was the last person about to get on
the plane and they cancelled the standby
list and they put on a bunch of their
own employees and they had the employees
fill the seat I was sick and I tweeted
waha ticked I was at American Airlines
at no point that I ever attacked the
actual employees who are standing in
front of me
at no point that I take their pictures
or suggest or put out their names or
suggest that they were the bad guys I
attack the airline because it's stupid
airline policy that sucks right it's not
the fault of the employees these are
people who are just going about their
daily business and whenever you're at
the airport you see somebody screaming
at an employee it's just nasty because
the fact is these are people trying to
do their jobs for the most part so an
tweeted out Joe here's what happened and
booked a seat with extra legroom then
blue heard from the flight but she got
there like five minutes before the
flight if you get there five minutes
before the flight they will probably
give away your seat and so they got her
on the flight but they didn't get her in
her original seat and she said just when
you think it's safe to fly them again
the worst airline in America is still
Delta suckiest Delta moved me from my
pre-book seat and give it to some woman
not elderly child or sick I have
pictures so don't why Delta and then she
continued along these lines and she
tweeted out a picture of the actual
woman sitting in her seat whose fault it
is not right okay it's fussy I think we
could all you Delta eventually tweeted
back at her they actually they said well
we're sorry you did not receive the
preferred seat you paid for and we'll
refund your $30 additionally
insults about our other customers and
employees are unacceptable and
unnecessary and and you know I again I'm
friends damn but I can't blame Delta
here I really can't I mean if you're
tweeting out photos of other passengers
who haven't done anything wrong or if
you're directly attacking the employees
I have a problem with this I think that
it's not not only is it not nice it
makes for a worse country I think it
just makes for a worse environment in
which we live we have to understand and
give each other the benefit of the doubt
that we're all trying to do a job and I
don't think that it's the Delta employ
like she's suggesting that it was some
sort of anti conservative bias maybe she
just showed up late for a flight and
they gave away her $30 she said that it
cost her ten thousand dollars because of
all the time it took for her to book
stuff okay I'm sorry no I'm sorry No
okay first of all I'm sure Anne has an
assistant but she doesn't she should get
one because if she's still booking her
own flights and she's doing it she's
wasting her time but it's but you know I
think that it's easy for those of us who
have some level of fame and prominence
to start treating people badly who are
in positions that are that are less
well-paid less famous and I just don't
as I can as a conservative and you know
as a religious person I'm just not a fan
I think you can rip the airline up and
down I don't care if it like she says
Delta Mata how can we make your flight
more uncomfortable see that's fine with
me I don't care like if you want to rip
Delta for doing it that's fine but
taking pictures of the people on the
flight which is what she did and then
ripping the staff at Delta as though
it's the staffs fault again unless she
has evidence of that I just that it's
not my cup of tea I'm not I'm not a big
fan you see this from right and left
it's not a right-left issue right I mean
they're they're people on the Left who
have done this as well very famously and
everybody needs to calm the hell down
when it comes to it when it comes to
travel okay so we'll be back here
tomorrow hopefully the news will will be
better I'd like to say it's supposed to
be make America work again week so
hopefully president Trump will stay on
message this week and it won't just be
and it won't just be more Russia talk
but all that depends on what happens
today so we'll see I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]